Bibi Netanyahu is the one that called
for Americans to invade Iraq, Libya,
Syria, Afghanistan, and now Iran, and
we've done it. And we're done with the
BS of, "Okay, well, we weren't really
They weren't really involved Israel in
Afghanistan." Because even when we fight
those never-ending wars, Israel wins.
There you go. There you go, spit In
fact, Candace is smashing the scene.
With all due respect, she is smashing
the scene.
We are teaching people how to pray.
>> And every time they pray, you get to
share in that reward. And when they
teach their children and their
children's children
the reward continues. Every Fajr Dhuhr
Asr
>> Maghrib Isha Every recitation for just
£100 you can help teach 20 to 60 people
>> like me learn how to pray salah. Donate
today.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh, brothers and sisters and dear
friends. Here's the moment where Candace
Owens absolutely shut up Piers Morgan
when it comes to facts and the bull crap
that he tries to propagate, which is
absolutely false. Now, Candace Owens is
not pro or against anything. She's pro
speaking the truth and speaking facts.
Here's what Piers Morgan had to say, and
look how Candace Owens
factually shut him up. Reason that
America wants a regime change in Iran is
because Bibi Netanyahu is demanding it.
And we also are completely done with the
idea that this decades-long idea that
we're doing it to spread democracy
because we believe in international
liberalism. Thank you, which is
absolutely nonsense. Uh trying to um
spread democracy. No, you're not. You
don't care about girls. You You bombed a
school. 160-plus
innocent Iranian girls were massacred.
Don't you dare come and talk about
liberating the women. You don't give a
crap about those women, okay? You done
the same in Iraq when you killed 1
million people, starved them. Half a
million Afghanistan. You don't give two
craps about democracy. You want to Yes,
it's demo- democracy when it suits you.
And you overthrow them when it suits you
with your proxy wars. So, it is
absolutely bull crap that you want to
save the Muslims and they've been
oppressed. Like, your way of life is
good. Having sex outside of marriage,
alcohol, gambling, murder, uh
pornography, degeneracy. No one No one
in the Muslim world is jealous of the
West. For all with all due respect,
okay? With all due respect. There was no
imminent threat to the United States
when Trump made the decision to do what
Bibi wanted. And I'm I want to be clear
here. This was not Trump's decision. It
was Bibi Netanyahu's decision. And that
is the reason that he did it. Exactly.
Not only that, it's like they call the
this uh this what is this this war
campaign, whatever it's called, Epic
Fury. Everyone knows it's Epstein Fury,
okay? Epstein Fury. We're very aware
that Israel is dictating our foreign
policy and we would now like that to
stop.
>> Okay, but you wouldn't just disagree,
presumably, that They are not just
dictating your foreign policy. They are
ruling you.
They rule America.
>> Iran has been the main sponsor of
terrorism in the Middle East through the
Houthis, through Hezbollah, through
Hamas. I mean, that's widely accepted
and recognized. They've done it.
>> think it's widely accepted. Now, that's
just kind of like
>> Really? Israel has been a terrorist
state, okay? Israel right now is
imparting a genocide and a holocaust on
the Gazan people. Uh so, I'm I'm really
over this idea like somehow Israel has
the moral high ground and we have to get
behind that.
>> say that. We've got to go after the bad
guys. So, it's it's it's it's rich to me
that I'm concerned about Iran having
[laughter] nukes.
What I'm concerned about Israel who
won't even admit that they have nukes
having Okay. But at the same time, they
are executing a genocide and a holocaust
in Gaza that the world is watching. So,
who's the bigger terrorist is the
question today. But when the leader of
Iran says Exactly. Israel is the biggest
terrorist. They have nuclear bombs. They
have the Samson option that they will
nuke anyone if their existence is
threatened. If there's anyone that is a
threat in the Middle East with their
nukes, it's Israel, okay? Are these
Zionist scums who are controlling They
want to know what goes in your water.
They are making sure your children watch
Disney with um subliminal messages. They
are satanic. You've seen what they do in
Epstein Island. You're seeing what they
do to American children. They are raping
you
They're pedophile scums that are raping
little children and then sending your
kids when they grow up to fight for
them. Okay? Cuz you are a Okay?
That's what it is. For their bigger plan
to prepare for the Antichrist, for the
greater Israel plan. Okay? That's what
they're doing. Hezbollah whatever this
for for that Whoever kills innocent
people we condemn. We are morally
consistent, not strategically. But the
question is
if Israel didn't go and steal those
lands
this would not be happening cuz the
Palestinians, the Muslims, and the Jews
have lived in those centuries in those
lands for centuries. Death to America.
Why doesn't that concern you? That Why
are they chanting death to America?
Thank you. Very vital question. Why are
they bored? What is it that they're
jealous about Americans? What is it?
Your cheeseburgers? What is it? Maybe
it's something to do with just like
killing a million Iraqi civilians
civilians, okay? Uh because BB Netanyahu
on a congressional stage and said there
are weapons of mass destruction and we
took that to the bank and there actually
were no weapons of mass destruction. So
we just killed a million. It could have
something I I I could be crazy. It could
have something to do with our actions in
the Middle East. Thank you. It's not
rocket science. Wallahi. It's
unbelievable.
You guys are the perpetrators and the
culprits of pedophilia. Killing and
massacring millions of innocent people
from Vietnam
to Hiroshima, Nagasaki, Muslims, you
name it. And you play the victim card.
Just imagine the people back in the day
when they would have to travel certain
distances for months or even years. What
is one thing that they would carry with
them?
The Quran.
>> [clears throat]
>> Why? Because they did not have it on
their mobile devices or their gadgets.
Brothers and sisters, imagine you have a
app, the Quranic app, which not only
shows you how much rewards you get, but
reminds you to read the Quran, gives you
reminders. Download the Quranic app now
and let it testify for you on Yom Kippur
that you read it wherever you was. And
you play the victim card. I mean, do you
think these
stupid crazy nuts who were carrying out
attacks in the UK under the name of
Islam? It's all because of your foreign
policy, not because Islam says this,
because you and they've they've
CIA agents, yes, officials have admitted
it's what we're doing in those regions
in Iraq. The we are killing we are
creating more terrorists than we are
killing on the ground because of your
foreign policy. You guys made ISIS. We
know that Bibi Netanyahu funded the
Al-Qaeda adjacent fronts because he
wanted to overthrow Syria. Bibi
Netanyahu funded Hamas. There is footage
of Bibi Netanyahu saying this stuff on
camera. So, it's just so ridiculous to
me to pretend that they're in some
predicament that they're
they may be eradicated soon, which is
why they have to keep funding all of
these terrorist groups and then Uh
Israel has been funding ISIS
in Syria.
Okay? To fight the proxy wars. They
don't care. They will fund whoever
wherever for the greater Israel plan and
as long as their people are not harmed
at the cost of anyone but their own
people because they're evil. They don't
see you guys as the same.
Look Allah says in the Quran if you kill
one soul it's it's the it's as if you
killed the whole of humanity. No, in
their time what they believe if you kill
one Jew it's as if you killed the whole
of humanity. Something like that. That's
what they believe. that they're victims
of terror of of terror when in fact they
are the people that are imparting it
worldwide, you know, okay? And again,
these never-ending wars in the Middle
East at the behest of Israel. Bibi
Netanyahu is the one that called for
Americans to invade Iraq, Libya, Syria,
Afghanistan, and now Iran and we've done
it and we're done with the BS of okay,
well, we weren't really they weren't
really involved Israel in Afghanistan
because even when we fight those
never-ending wars, Israel wins.
Everybody knows that our boys were out
there in Afghanistan guarding poppy
fields, okay? And do you know what
happened after we allegedly
quote-unquote lost in Afghanistan? What
happened to all those poppy fields, uh
those poppy flowers that our military
was guarding? Well, the opioid crisis
hit America via the Sackler family who
quite literally built the School of
Medicine at Tel Aviv University. There
you go. There you go, spit. In fact,
Candace is smashing the scene. With all
due respect, she is smashing the scene
and she is literally speaking the truth.
It's those poppy farms that goes back to
the pharmaceutical industry in America.
They don't care about you. They don't
care. So, we're just done, okay? And
there's no way that we're going to go
backwards. We're not going to allow you
guys to emotionally condition us to go,
"Oh, well, we got to protect Israel
because of the Holocaust." It is over.
They're imparting a holocaust. America
would like off this crazy train.
Alhamdulillah. Fantastic. They are not
going to use this. Jews are speaking out
against this. You can't use the
Holocaust card and act like you're the
victim forever. They're not buying it
anymore. You guys are a shame and you
guys are You guys are the biggest
anti-Semites.
Yes. For those people who actually died
in the Holocaust, you will bring shame
to them to see that what they went
through you're doing it to the Gazans.
You scums. You Zionists are scums. Don't
ever conflate uh conflate a Jew, a true
Orthodox Jew to these Zionists dirtbags
that are trying to reverse engineer the
coming of the Antichrist. Yes, or their
Messiah.
Brothers and sisters, till next time.
As-salamu alaykum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh. Alhamdulillah. Candace
Owens shows that Allah says in the
Quoran says in the Quoran.
Like Allah says in the Quoran
The people of the book are not the same.
Subhanallah. And Candace Owens, you can
see clearly from that Subhanallah.
She's consistent. Not like this dog, no
logic, who is aiding and being on the
side of the Israelis. And that's how
much their hatred their hatred for Islam
is greater than their love for their own
religion. And I applaud Khana Sohaib for
being consistent. Till next time,
assalamualaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh.